all right so it's officially the holiday
season and i don't think there is a
better way to get into it than with a
giveaway
[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the 600
custom built pc giveaway not this one
but we'll get to that in a second so for
this i'm partnering up with austin from
duncan 33303 as you probably already
know him to give away a 600
windows build that's built in a case not
like this but very cool looking you've
probably heard of it it's a case from
bitfenix and it's pretty awesome looking
and he's doing a series right now on how
to actually build this pc so he's picked
out all the parts the budget is laid
together and you can view the link down
below in the description he's doing the
whole series on how to build the whole
thing but we're giving one away all you
need to do to enter in order to win this
one pc here is to be subscribed to both
of our channels so that link will be
down below the like button on this video
or in these two annotations right here
and all you have to do to enter to get
an entry is to leave a comment down
below this video and if you want another
one you can go leave a comment on his
video you can get a maximum of two
entries it doesn't really matter how
many comments you leave here because
you're only going to get one you get
your name into the pool once and if you
leave a comment on his video you get
your name into that poll too this turns
out to be a pretty nice value windows 8
build and i've actually started getting
some windows 8 experience myself and i
kind of like it from what i've tried i
didn't i wasn't really into the metro
thing at first but it looks pretty nice
so this would definitely make a sweet
holiday gift speaking of holiday gifts
this giveaway ends in exactly two weeks
from today
which is christmas so that's definitely
a good sign and you're going to want to
stay tuned because we're going to
announcing that on twitter so the links
down below the like button on this video
will also lead you to twitter and you'll
be able to follow us there for updates
on this should be pretty simple just a
random drawing for one winner of this pc
other than that that's it that's all you
need to do to get entered i will be
building a build in this case right here
if you want to know this is the fractal
design r4
it's pretty much a boss and i will be
building a build in this during the
winter break so the coming weeks i'll be
picking out parts with you guys on
twitter on facebook on google plus and
we might make a hackintosh out of this
if you guys are up to it so definitely
let me know on twitter and we'll be uh
building some stuff in here very shortly
either way that's basically it thanks
for watching just a quick video get you
guys something for the holiday season
giving back and we'll talk to you guys
in the next one which should be yet
another collab
peace
[Music]
you